bene a tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono famiglie oggi siamo
tornati su un gioco chiaro è una vita
che non facevano romano secondo episodio
non l'ho mai più fatto
facciamolo oggi siamo tornati ragazzi su
chi the falls che sarebbe persone
nascoste nelle cose hanno aggiunto
ragazzi su twitter fox nelle dei dlc e
per quello che volevo farlo che si
tratta della spiaggia che è praticamente
studi lc incredibile dove ti permette di
trovare le persone sulla spiaggia adesso
il nostro se vi ricordate com'era i
default
rihanna non è venuto qui per
l'abbronzatura e frutta per l'atmosfera
holligans in the world proprio allora
tutto so cosa vuol dire questo gioco tu
hai dei personaggi e delle degli oggetti
da trovare
cioè lui ti dice negli oggetti to ride
di trovare in mezzo tutto sto schifo ok
la partenza non è male perché la
partenza in questo caso c'è poca roba ma
vi assicuro sono avete visto più
episodio che poi diventa un casino
comunque devo trovare occhiali kaspar mi
vuoi sposare chiese la palma che non so
cosa sia a un anello c'è un anello
vicino una palma probabilmente ecco a
perfetto
rihanna l'ho trovata ora devo tornare
gli occhiali sappiamo di essere
difficile vedere ma per favore non
mettere il tuo fondoschiena su di noi
c'è qualcuno che cialde l'età non su sti
occhiali troviamo il kitsch al culo
all'aria kitsch al culo alla reato è
strano perché non vedo la sua forse
perché sono su una sedia o su un secchio
a perché posso togliere al contratto
kaspar che non so chi sia
va bene perché devo anche spostare le
cose non dimentica eccoli perfetto e
dopodiché c'è
l'anello che cosa ho detto prima che
spesso alla vicina alle palme da qualche
piccolo ce l'ho fatta ragazzi primo
livello fantastico prepara un te l'ho
trovato preparo presa prepara un telo in
questo momento ragazzi ce l'abbiamo nel
occhio che bello quando arrivano questi
momenti nella mia vita sono proprio
contento bene spero che vi sia piaciuto
allora partiamo al primo ed anisa è
giunto il turno di qualcun altro per
godersi la tenda per feste da una
persona tenda per feste tenda per feste
che tenda a tenda eccoci tenda per feste
da una persona cosa vuol dire una
persona
eccola non è che sembrava del diavolo è
esci
eccola l'ho trovato allora era la prima
c'è notte non è l'unica l'addormentarsi
al sole ma è l'unica non voler essere
svegliata anche io per ora quindi devo
andare dove quella gente prende il sole
chiede prende il sole in spiaggia
nessuno porca vacca barca dove dovrei
trovarle impossibile lotta non è l'unica
ad ogni intercettazione ma è l'unica a
non voler essere svegliata sta
semplicemente dormendo al sole va dove
no ragazzi incredibile c'è troppa gente
ma porca vacca ma cos'è venice beach la
spiaggia così grosse nella mia vita non
l'ho mai vista per acqua sta pezzente ma
basta un'ora sono stato un ora
maledizione quando cercavo di trovare le
mie sufficienza nel libretto di
matematica barene qualcuno può togliere
la pallina da golf ed al passo di gaby
prima di che prima che soffro dal passo
dal fasto quindi io devo trovare sta
tizia qua che sta mangiando immagino sia
fare un pic nic a no aspetta c'è l'area
picnic dal passo di gavi ok quindi i
capi sta mangiando per i suoi tavoli ok
questa qui sta mangiando io devo levare
la pallina da golf dal tavolo
correttamente così come
ha detto vero non ho detto proprio e si
muovono quindi devo spostare l'ho
trovato subito che vista aguzzino non si
dice vista aguzzino però l'unico mina
abbastanza agile sia esattamente come fa
l'insegnante di yoga in questo
particolare esercizio
beh questa testa in giù se non lo becco
stupido chi è che fa yoga come faccio a
saperlo
all insegnante di yoga sarà in spiaggia
immagino ci siamo ispirati volevo dire
il segnale sarà in piscina si fa lo yoga
in piscina
l'insegnante di yoga o c'è questo non è
in realtà non è yoga stanno ballando
quindi bo però è una sorta di yoga e
questo questo sembrava questo eppure
sembra perché lo devo trovare coloro
dolori quella posizione porca vacca non
sapevo neanche voi ce l'ho riconosciuto
perché lavori per forza dei vestiti è
uguale però mamma mia
beh però brava lady avanti la pena di
quindi devo anche esposta mammamia un
bordello come ci sarà qualcosa su di sé
che io lo so io lo so fa ebbe a posto
proprio a caso non volevo ma va bene
secondo me i ragazzi a parte gli scherzi
potrei cercare di trovare delle cose
strane che accadono e dischi e di
cliccare su quelle berco più probabilità
di trovare gente a caso come ho appena
fatto che gente che effettivamente sto
cercando però è che ci sono anche degli
oggetti non solo gente prof
vabbè schiacciare a caso non è il
massimo però se vediamo robe sospette
io schiacce ray perché a quanto pare si
trova gente anche il chelsea trovano
robe anche così quindi facciamo
ricordiamoci questa tecnica che non deve
sottovalutare gli avanti
basta lorenzo schiacciare cose a caso
camon adesso effettivamente basta ok
c'era aic che ha trovato bene la pena di
palline bianche potrebbe staccarsi dalla
pallina da golf nera per favore la pila
di palline via allora ecco la pila di
palline piano cane che insegue la palla
fina di palline di eccola qua
mamma mia che vista l'aria questi tre
venditori ambulanti sono pirati non ci
si può più fidare tre venditori
ambulanti sono bello su ruote sono
venditori ambulanti treat rino che i
venditori ambulanti sono ladri quindi
devo trovare un oggetto vicino ai
venditori ambulanti che sono ambulanti
odia che sono ambulante di grandi giro
non stanno fermi granchio normale o a
caso strano cose completamente errando
gaspar voleranno nella roma di prima
lega l'asparago bene
in tutto questo volevo cercare la roba
turisti delle leggi della natura è uno e
uno con il come si chiama con il con
l'aquilone sfida leggi della natura vuol
dire che lo sta facendo sugli alberi o
una roba del genere allegato qualcosa al
suo coso me vede eccolo qua a non ce
l'aveva non ce l'aveva proprio ce l'ho
fatto sbloccato l'escursione fa in giro
in barca a vela proviamoci ragazzi stavo
schermo per questa sembra abbastanza
easy ma l'ho detto eccolo romino ha
inquadrato subito ma non avevo capito
questo meno ok a cavolo dovuto sono
dovuto uscire rientrare perché pistaroli
ok allora immagino che ci siano cose che
succedono tipo io devo devo todi devo
spianargli la strada va bene
proviamoci raga quali problemi potrà mai
riscontrare per arrivare lì ci arrivava
inquadrato subito che pirla alla fin qua
ci siamo la barca a vela sta in fondo
storicamente via i cosi che sono tipo
paguri ok occhio ma sai nuotare almeno
ho capito la nota non sa nuotare cosa
devo fare qua devo levare tutti gli
ostacoli va bene ci devo accompagnarlo
ma ricordavo sta roba che dovevo
aiutarlo ad arrivare a un certo punto
c'era anche nelle altre mappe ok poi ci
sono i gorilla attenzione questa parte
la vedo difficile perché chissà come
faccio a farmi fuori
ok ok gol che continua ad averli tolti
perfetto perfetto perfetto normale non
male porca vacca buonissimo bravo ce
l'ho fatta credo ce l'ho fatta perché
una cosa manca scusami cosa bank adesso
dovrà aggiungere la sua barca a vela è
questa la sua barca a vela e dovrei aver
fatto questi cosa fanno gli agguati
teoricamente ce l'ho fatta ai ragazzi
teoricamente fermi lì non osate non
osate vi ammazzo teoricamente fatto lo
poi non lo so se arrivato manca la vela
a ce l'hai
manca la vela ha fatto adesso loro
spiana la strada per andare fuori in
mare aperto scorretto e a salpare via ok
sta salpando via
ciao qualcuno nella poco davanti no ciò
dovrebbe fatta questo non era
difficilissimo non era difficilissimo
vediamo come il prossimo signori spero
che vi sia piaciuto a queste rapide
nforce molto bello come gioco mi piace
perché è un gioco diversissimo da tutto
quello che potete trovare in giro
allora vi sia piaciuto ragazzi iscritti
dichiarare lo stato mi piace un commento
e il truck e cliccata la campanella che
è come sempre di far rimanere
su tutto quello che esce quindi ci
vediamo ragazzi non possiamo vicino ad
un durissimo vedo bene ragazzi
[Musica]